well I wrote the book because I wanted
to reach more women with women are very
frustrated when they can't get where
they want to go or if they feel they're
being thwarted in the workplace in and I
wrote the book so I could reach more
women more frustrated women and try and
keep them in the workforce I I don't
really want to convince women to not to
stay home and take care of their
families if that's what they want to do
I applaud them for that but I also
applaud the women who are trying to do
both who trying to have a family and
also get as far as they want to go in
their jobs and and I thought the book
would help them I thought writing it
with a sense of humor would help them
you know get through it and keeping it
like a swift page-turning read would be
better for them and and and and I tried
not to make it a ponderous you know book
of do's and don'ts because then
advertising I learned that if you you
have to entertain people in order to get
them to remember what you want them to
remember and that's how I tried to write
the book and that's why you see phrases
in there like the art of S&M and
flirting with integrity and there's not
much of that but that's what pops out
there's a lot of information in there
about how women and men can work better
with each other so and I just thought it
was time to something for somebody to
write a book like that
I think that the big takeaway for me is
and I try to do this daily is to have
the men get more in touch with their
female side and the women to get more in
touch with their male side without
losing each other in the process and you
know I say that to the men and their
they say funny things like oh if I had a
female side I'd be touching it all the
time I go that's not what I mean so you
know you have to laugh at that but
pretty funny I'm gonna but that's what
you're up against when you're dealing
with boys club
you